[Music]
[Music]
I don't know if you guys are doing in
the control room but we may got a two
minute
oh good afternoon we just finished the
Monday meeting of the white house corona
buyers task force since the time the
president established a task force here
at the White House he has literally met
daily and we continued that effort today
we added the head of the Center for
Medicaid and Medicare services Seema
Verma to the task force today as well as
Robert Wilkie with the VA first a few of
basic facts and reports and then we'll
hear from some other members of the task
force about ongoing efforts at the
present moment we have 43 domestic cases
of the corona virus 48 cases of
individuals who have returned to the
United States of the domestic cases 29
of the 43 are either in California or
Washington State and we have we have
communities that are facing facing what
the experts tell us could potentially be
a cluster in those communities sadly
today there were four additional
fatalities raising the number of the
that six Americans have lost their life
to the corona virus and on behalf of the
President and all of the American people
we extend our deepest condolences and
sympathies to the families of those that
were lost despite today's sad news let's
be clear the risk to the American people
of the corona virus remains low
according to all of the experts that
were working with across the government
as the president has said we're ready
for anything but this is an
all-hands-on-deck effort today's
activity really reflects the president's
effort to bring the best minds of
private industry together the best
leadership from around the country at
every level we had a good meeting this
morning with governor's from 50 states
and three territories I was able to
convey to them the gratitude that the
president our entire
ministration feels particularly for
governor's that are dealing with the
coronavirus in their states those that
have taken repatriated personnel I can
say that what I hear from the nation's
governor's is that there has been a
seamless relationship between all the
agencies of the federal government and
States thus far and and and we're
encouraged to hear that but I told them
that we are committed to a full
partnership with state governments and
to their health officials and to local
health care providers going forward we
also met today with some of the leaders
of the top pharmaceutical companies in
the country the president spoke to them
not just about vaccines which many of
the companies are already beginning to
work on but just as importantly of the
development of therapeutics and it is
remarkable to think that there may well
be a vaccine going to clinical trials
within the next six weeks the nature of
trials as the experts have explained to
us is that the vaccine might yet not be
available until late this year or early
next for the therapeutics giving relief
to people the contract the coronavirus
could literally be available by this
summer or early fall the most
encouraging news from that meeting was
that our pharmaceutical companies which
are recognized as the greatest in the
world all have already formed a
consortium to work together to share
information in the development of
therapeutics and vaccines a quick update
yesterday we were fully implementing the
the new travel advisories for portions
of Italy and South Korea and the
implementation of screening of personnel
from from across those countries who are
trying to take a direct flight to the
United States of America I was pleased
in the White House Task Force meeting
today to learn that within the next 12
hours there will be a hundred percent
screening all direct flights at all
airports
across Italy and across South Korea the
president has directed us to bring the
full resources of the federal government
and to bring the very best minds in this
country to bear on this effort and
finally today I'm pleased to welcome to
our White House team a world-renowned
global health official and a physician
she will be my right arm through this
effort as the president has tasked me to
lead the White House response to the
corona virus and I'm grateful that
ambassador deborah birx also dr. deborah
birx
will be on our team and even on her
first day she's already been
contributing significantly to our
discussions dr. Berg serves as the US
government's leader today for combating
hiv/aids globally and has developed an
international reputation as that she's a
scientist a physician someone with three
decades of public health expertise
including virulent diseases vaccines and
has vast experience in interagency
coordination and dr. Burks and I have
talked about the importance of bringing
all of these various entities together
to bring about president Trump's vision
for a whole-of-government response to
the corona virus so with that I'd like
to recognize dr. deborah birx for a few
of introductory and welcome remarks and
thank you for stepping up one more time
to serve our country thank you
Thank You mr. vice president it's a
pleasure to be here I just arrived from
South Africa last night everybody took
great care of me I had computer and
phone and record time it really shows
the level of efficiency and expertise
here to really get moving quickly it's
clear that the early work of the
president both the travel restrictions
and the ability to quarantine has bought
us this time and space to have this task
force be very effective I have never
worked switch such incredible scientists
and thoughtful policy leaders and I got
to spend the day with them I'm trying to
get up to speed as fast as possible and
I look forward to the days I've had
really working together to end
epidemic Thank You secretary well thank
you mr. vice president um I just want to
first start out by saying how delighted
we are that ambassador birx
is gonna be leading coordinating these
efforts across the government dr. Burks
and I go way back dr. Burks and
basically every leader at the Department
of Health and Human Services go way back
together
so we already have established
relationships and we already have very
established productive working
relationships that I think are gonna
keep the interagency process working
incredibly smoothly and as the vice
president said dr. Burks already has
been asking the right questions and
challenging us on all the right
scientific and in policy matters that we
need to focus on I just want to begin by
recapping the current situation that we
face with kovat 19 as the vice president
mentioned as of this morning we have a
forty-three confirmed or presumptive
cases of the virus in the United States
excluding our repatriated cases 17 of
those cases are travel related in one
way or another
26 are believed to be person-to-person
spread because of the president's strong
leadership and all of the hard work that
our public health professionals have
done at the local the state the federal
level the immediate risk to any
individual American has been and does
continue to be low but the risk for
people with possible exposure to
identified cases can be high what every
one of our experts and leaders have been
saying for more than a month now remains
true the degree of risk has the
potential to change quickly especially
if we see sustained spread of the
disease around the world which could
qualify this disease as a pandemic as
dr. Fauci said this morning we will see
more cases of community spread in the
United States as we've emphasized for
some time now we all need to prepare for
the potential need prepare for the worst
hope for the best in some places we will
have to use the range of our mitigation
efforts in fact we already are working
closely with Santa Clara
and the state of Washington in
particular King County to assist them in
thinking through some of the best
practices from our pandemic action plan
as well as learnings from Singapore and
Hong Kong around the most effective
community mitigation efforts such as
temporary school closures or even more
titrated responses dr. Hsu katas talk to
you about such as having school but
perhaps not having assemblies in school
that's why the president has taken an
unprecedented whole-of-government
approach to protecting the American
people including the steps in the last
few days to radically expand and improve
the testing that we have and to improve
access to respirators needed by
healthcare workers the vice president
dr. shook it of the CDC and I spoke with
basically almost every governor that we
have this morning and we greatly
appreciate their close cooperation with
us I also wanted to now introduce an
individual who I asked the vice
president to have joined this task force
because the Centers for Medicare and
Medicaid Services play such a vital role
1.3 trillion dollars of spending here in
the United States providing health care
to 60 million American seniors and as
we've seen this disease can have a
disproportionate severity impact on the
elderly as well as the medically frail
and so Seema Verma our administrator has
a very important responsibility with
regard to funding of care whether it's
therapeutics or vaccines or Diagnostics
for our senior citizens but also a vital
role that you may not know of in
regulating long term care facilities
such as nursing homes and other health
care facilities a very important
regulatory function so I'm delighted
that administrator Verma is formally
joining the task force and let me turn
it over to Seema house Thank You
secretary azar so for the trump
administration and CMS patients come
first in the health and the safety and
welfare of America's patients and
provider workforce is our highest
priority so let me start with what CMS
and as the secretary said we are the
nation's largest insurer covering over a
hundred and thirty million Americans
between Medicare Medicaid and the
individual insurance market and some of
these are our nation's most vulnerable
populations those in poverty the elderly
and children and so forth
critically we do have a regulatory
responsibility for pretty much every
health care institution in America this
includes facilities such as hospitals
critical access hospitals nursing homes
home health agencies dialysis facilities
surgery centers than the list goes on
and that gives us a very critical role
in addressing the coronavirus we are
responsible for enforcing the quality
guidelines based in part on information
from partner agencies like the CDC and
so let me stress that CMS has
long-standing infectious disease
policies already in place that we've
used effectively for other outbreaks
such as influenza and so health care
facilities already have these procedures
in place and should be prepared for what
they may see and we're gonna continue to
proactively update our regulations we're
gonna be working with with CDC right now
like I said those are already in place
and it's our job to make sure that
health care facilities are effectively
implementing those guidelines and we
will work with the CDC to determine
whether we need to update or change
those also we are looking at what we
cover and clarifying the types of
products and services that our programs
will be able to pay for in terms of
Medicaid and Medicare thank you for
stepping up I want to recognize a couple
other members of our team Tony found you
thank you doctor yeah thank you very
much mr. vice president I just want to
make three three comments and points
first of all to underscore with the vice
president and with secretary as I said
we had a really extraordinary meeting
with the CEOs a variety of individuals
in the pharmaceutical and biotech
business several of whom were in the
room were people were actually already
actively collaborating with
and their enthusiasm about getting
involved in helping us along with the
development of products and the
availability of products be they
vaccines monoclonal antibodies and
therapeutics it was very gratifying
second I'm very pleased that the
president and vice president will be
visiting the NIH tomorrow we're gonna
have the opportunity to show them
firsthand in real time the kinds of
things we were doing and finally just
one comment about ambassador dr. Burks
so a couple of people up here said you
know I go back a long time with dr.
Burks nobody goes back as long as I go
with ambassador birx she was actually a
fellow in my program as a trainee and we
knew she was a star then and now what
has happened over the years she's become
a superstar together we saw the first
patients with HIV back in the early 80s
we were involved in a vaccine trial that
was the first successful trial with HIV
we've known each other through PEPFAR I
had the privilege and the honor among
others of putting together the PEPFAR
program for President Bush and she was
the ambassador in charge of the PEPFAR
program so I can't tell you how excited
I am to finally once again get back and
being a partner with Debbie Burks and
and finally a dr. Bob Redfield CDC Bob
thank you mr. vice president what I
would like to do is is just recognize
that CDC continues to work and provide
support to really the backbone of our
public health system in this nation
which is a state local tribal and
territorial health departments and these
teams continue to work to identify new
cases isolate and contact trace these
two together to work together to try to
limit the transmission of the corona
virus and working with our public health
partners we continue to be able to
identify new community cases as the
secretary said we always anticipated and
use our public health assets to
aggressively again
confirm those cases isolate do contact
tracing to use our public health tools
to limit the spread of this virus I want
to echo said by the Vice President and
the secretary that despite seeing these
new community cases that shows you we
have a public health community across
this country in action the risk to the
American people is low I also want to
add my looking forward I know my tire
agency is looking forward to the
president and the vice presidents and
the Secretary's visit to come to Atlanta
on Friday and get to meet a lot of the
wonderful people that from form the
backbone of this great agency thank you
thank you questions Steve Holland
Reuters where is Dean how quickly do you
expect this virus to spread throughout
the United States let me let me refer to
that to the experts Washington State
I think the important thing as the
Secretary has said from the beginning
we've anticipated to see community cases
pop up and now we have a number of new
community cases which the health
department's are aggressively evaluating
to see if they can understand the
linkage who were the contacts how is
this virus spreading and I think the
American public should rest assured we
have one of the finest public health
programs in the world when you look at
the state and local territorial so we're
going to continue to see these cases as
a consequence of them doing their job
and we're going to use the public health
strategies that we can to limit that
transmission and I think we should focus
on that right now we're still working
very hard in trying to contain these
community outbreaks but as the Secretary
has said we are blending that now with
very strategic mitigation strategies so
so just to underscore something I said
the other day that there are two aspects
of this is about cases coming in and
then controlling the situation of the
spread of what's already in here and
there are two things that are going on
it's the kind of restrictions of travel
to areas where there hot spots in the
rest of the world just like the original
inhibition of travel here with China I
think is gonna mitigate against the
question of the wider spread and the
contact tracing and the isolation that's
very aggressively going on I mean we
hope you could never predict 100% of
anything but I think what's going on
right now with the CDC and particularly
the state and local health authorities
is gonna really I think get us through
this Steve it's something I learned I
learned along the way is that when we
have cases that emerge state and local
health officials are in the lead but CDC
is on the ground immediately helping to
identify how that how that might have
originated with that individual to find
out any other people that they've been
exposed to but we know there will be
more cases the president initially took
unprecedented action to do all that we
could to prevent the corona virus coming
into the country and now we're focused
on mitigation of the spread as well as
treatment of the people that are
affected Krista
Fisher Kristen Fisher here she walked
out let me go let me go with the Hallie
Jackson few questions for you sir
anybody wants to jump in number one
president Trump hinted today at the
potential for new travel restrictions on
top Wolverine Italy South Korea China
Iran can you elaborate on specifically
what countries here with me have just
Germany for example which has seen some
cases when he spreads that on the stage
now the president is very clear we're
we're going to follow the facts and
listen to the experts every step of the
way the action the president authorized
this weekend
raising the travel advisory the American
people should know that we are saying
that they you should not travel to
certain sections of Italy or South Korea
those advisories may expand but will
will allow the case the caseload in
those countries to define that in
addition to that by establishing the
screening protocol which will be in full
force and effect within the next 12
hours in both countries will ensure that
anyone traveling on a direct flight to
the United States of America receives
multiple screenings at all airports in
Italy in South Korea but to your point
the nature of the European Union is one
doesn't require a passport to move
around so our our task force spoke today
about new cases and there were some in
several European countries we're
following that very closely
and again we'll listen to the experts
will watch the cases and and I know the
president will make the decisions with
regard to both travel advisories or
restrictions on the basis of those facts
do you do your experts behind you here
you consider this now a pandemic in all
that designation only I would I would
just refer to the experts that our view
is that would be for the World Health
Organization to define and our team our
task force team was in touch with the
World Health Organization today we and
let me let the secretary address that
but you know this isn't so much about
semantics I think our briefing today was
were in more than 60 countries at this
point and so we're going to continue to
focus on ensuring that we do all we can
to prevent people coming into the
country with the disease to mitigate any
spread of the disease once we identify
cases and of course to provide treatment
so I spoke with dr. Ted Rose today and
dr. Mike Ryan need an incident manager
for the World Health Organization about
this precise question because wanted to
get a sense of their thinking how
they're assessing the designation of
pandemic status and I'll let them fully
speak for themselves but right at the
moment while we're seeing community
spreading in multiple regions of the
world there's there's not a there's
there are many definitions that people
use around pandemic and one issue that
the w-h-o is focused on is just sheer
magnitude and while we've had very large
numbers of cases and spreading within
China the actual absolute number of
cases outside of China while reflecting
community spreading are not of the
magnitude comparable to any other
pandemics that have been declared before
for instance even the h1n1 where you
have billions of individuals infected
across the world so that's what there
that's how they are thinking about this
and we're just gonna keep working with
them we don't have a view as to whether
they should designated a pandemic or not
a pandemic I made that very clear I just
wanted to get a sense how they're
thinking about it and assessing it and
that's I think reflective of their
current thinking there but I'll let them
I asked them if they could put out some
points about how they're assessing this
though good answer hang on how about
been with ABC where are you been go
ahead screening passengers
in Italy in South Korea what exactly
what that screening would look like is
that people temperatures is that every
single passenger who will be conducting
it and will it be expanded to other
countries and then how many number how
many tests have been conducted last week
I believe secretary but said there were
3600 what's an update on that well let
me just our State Department is in a
interagency group has worked out that
arrangement with both Italy and South
Korea South Korea actually about three
hours ago fully implemented the
screening on all direct flights all
airports and as I mentioned within the
next twelve hours or so Italy will have
implemented the same thing it will be
multiple temperature checks in the
airports for people before they are
boarding and we're working very closely
to assist them in implementing that but
let me let me speak about dr. Ahn yeah
dr. Hong can speak to you about the
status of tests because one of the
things I heard from governors last week
was the whole issue of of test kits the
availability of testing and I really
want to commend dr. Han in the FDA for
some very Swift work making it many more
tests available more kits that include
multiple tests and also authorizing
local testing which which will now make
it more possible as our experts told us
to identify additional cases as we find
more cases it will mean our health
officials are doing their job in large
part and and the availability of those
tests will contribute to that as you
heard from the secretary and the vice
president this weekend we had the
capacity in state public health labs to
perform between 75,000 and a hundred
thousand tests when Saturday we issued
new policy allowing us to have some
flexibility regulatory flexibility
around the development of those tests so
academic centers private companies can
develop these tests tell us that they
validated
test and then begin to use them they
alert us of that and then later on
within 15 days we can look at the
validation data they're having the
responsibility to show the validation of
those tests with this new policy we've
heard from multiple companies and
multiple academic centers and we expect
to have a substantial increase in the
number of tests this week next week and
throughout the month they'll be is that
the estimates that we're getting from
industry right now by the end of this
week close to a million tests will be
able to be performed but with so two
tests being done and the incubation rate
being as much as two weeks how can we
accurately say that the risk is low at
this point we haven't put out a million
tests if you talk about the entire
country the whole 360 million people in
this country the risk is a low risk I
think the point you're making is that
since we haven't done yet but we'll
happen really soon
the testing into the community how do we
know the risk is low I would imagine
it's still gonna be low regardless of
that what happens in real time which is
the reason why we do this so frequently
is that things can change
but right now today on this day Monday
if you look at the country as a whole
the risk is low as the country are
worried about spring break should worry
about spring break and wondering if they
should book traveler or cancelled their
toggle the start of two parts one is
what is the expert opinion from the Task
Force on sort of spring Greek travel and
even domestic travel and secondly
would you yourself feel comfortable
bringing your family right now including
your three grandchildren and their
partners on a week-long trip to Disney
World
well I can say there's been no
recommendation about any limitations on
travel within the United States of
America but let me let the experts speak
to recommendations with regard to travel
I might wrap across this country all the
time my kids live all over the country
and look this is a time to use common
sense good time to wash your hands and
at this time of year that's always a
good decision but as we said the risk
remains low and well while we've had a
tragic loss as for today the the the
reality is as I said 29 of the 43
domestic cases are in California and in
Washington State and are centered in
very specific areas that we're working
to identify the source on but but I
don't I think people should just
continue to use common sense this time
of year and but with with regard to
international travel let me let me deal
to the expert well I just want to echo
what the vice president said that we
want people to go about and live their
normal lives in this nation right now
the Secretary's right even before the
coronavirus if you had asked CDC what
you should do about preparedness we
would give you that every individual
should think ahead and prepare whether
it's a hurricane those recommendations
haven't changed and I really want people
to reflect that in going to your laut
there's no travel restrictions in the
United States the CDC in the State
Department the task force have worked
hard to recognize those areas where
there's significant community
transmission where we give you advice
that we would recommend you not travel
there and you know that China is that we
now have South Korea as a level 3 we
have Italy Japan and Iran as level 3
travel advisories which we would ask you
to reconsider the
travel plans but in the United States
there's no travel restrictions I want to
echo again what everyone said the risk
to the American public at this point is
low we are going to increase
substantially of surveillance so I
wonder what we do for flu we have
multiple different surveillance systems
with dr. Hahn's of an FDA getting more
and more tests out those surveillance
systems are going to be activated in in
the near future and we'll have eyes on
whether there is any significant new
evidence of community pockets around
this nation with regard to with regard
to international travel we just will
continue to monitor the cases we'll
follow the facts the experts and the
science and determine whether additional
travel advisories or restrictions are
warranted that being said folks we're
going to slip out we will be back let me
tell you we will be back here if I may
we'll be back here every day get used to
seeing us we're gonna bring the experts
in we're gonna make sure and give you
the best and most high-quality real-time
information the best people in the world
see
kind
howdy y'all can hear your manager call
you little feet army
[Music]
my marsupial we're talking at home
Yoga harness or about about you what to
channel
honey we're not trying that don't we may
fight whatever fool
yes who is empowered in place on our
rack to our class might remind home -
host Elizabeth wait Alan usually outer
corner i know we got a shock wave hello
John Barbara again and my mother with
other what I don't wanna do that sound
oh yeah Natalie